you need to tell us without my god I'm
getting really scared now I've never had
and you got
cool with waiting where everything is
over my control
totally
it took me outside uncuffed me to a tree
ah you know you're in trouble you know
if its brief do I don't think about any
guns had it asked me the questions again
oh did you get that guy I did Perry guys
at the Saudi
I was hung in the tree for some time
the pain was indescribable
this passion comes in and he introduced
himself as working for the British
Consulate is there anything I can do to
help now I'm hanging in a tree and as
watch to me is that anything I can do to
help you get me down from his teammate
Gordon there's nothing they either I or
the British government can do to
interfering in foreign legal affairs
figure can be dignity why are you just
sort of and he went the next man and I'm
hit with vaults
they're using a cattle prod on mashhad
right the pain is utterly intense your
eyeballs want to pop out your head
someone I think I'm ready cuz you're
saying no do you want to tell us if you
brought any guns in please stop asking
cuz I've never brought any guns and they
were smuggled any good and then it
happens again I lost track of days
you